[Music]
you're listening to
inside of you with michael rosenbaum
holy crap
ryan you know i feel bad
i think you know obviously bad things
come in three right
yeah that's right so then hopefully good
things start happening so and i think it
happens you know
obviously a lot of things are going on
but we have the world we have the
pandemic we have
people have their issues and
um you know with the stress and the
anxiety
come more things that you're just like
holy [ __ ]
uh you know i talked about my dog one
week
and i don't normally have any
i think in each intro i usually i'm like
oh you know
i got stressed guys you know i have a
few cigarettes you know this and that
uh the dog my dog irv
and uh so it's just non-stop you almost
died
you know i got them back together i
guess
just going doctor after doctor i have
like four different
dermatologist eye doctor because he went
blind at one point
um then he had an infection in his foot
and so i don't know i don't know if the
antibiotics are are working but
you know he's in good spirits he's not
in any pain but it just seems like
[ __ ] another doctor i get a splint
got it now he has another infection in
his in his paw and i'm just like
gosh it's so frustrating i'm like okay a
good deal
and then last week and thank you
everyone uh i wasn't really
you know i contemplated telling
everybody that i got you know a mole
removed and it was skin cancer
because i was like i don't want to freak
people out it's not you know i'm not i'm
not
honestly not worried about it so i don't
know online people are obviously
wonderful and they have big hearts and
everybody's like oh i'm wishing you and
you know and look
uh thank you for the messages but the
point was
to just say to everybody like hey you
know
i played a guy on tv i i got skin cancer
so so can you it's just so people just
take a look at stuff differently and
maybe
you know go go look at that so it's not
too late that was the point of
doing that um honestly because i was
contemplating not even talking about it
and then i was and then this week uh
i'm just telling you yeah i just told
you i i was
i didn't want to like surprise you again
on the podcast you get surprised against
oh and i thought about it oh crap i
should just tell ryan right now
but uh my dad remarried many years ago
and he had a you know a wonderfully
healthy child ava who's amazing my
sister
and then they had another baby leah
little leah
and she was uh you know she had a
chromosomal
i don't know what you call it a defect
maybe i i don't know exactly it's called
trisomy it's a very rare thing but
pretty much you know most children that
have this they die
pretty fast they don't live long lives
and um
somehow as nails this little thing
uh this little girl leah she she lived
to 15 years
now what that entails is you think oh 15
years that's great well
it wasn't like she had a fun life she
was in the hospital
her entire life you know she couldn't
really speak and she
you know um she couldn't walk
and uh she you know just a tough life
but you know my uh stepmother and my
father they just you know they loved her
with everything you love your child i
couldn't possibly understand what it's
like to
um deal with a sick child let alone a
child
i had to deal with it which i can barely
deal with my child self
and so you know she
was sick and sick and sick and you know
you're inclined i think as a parent
to you listen to your heart i was
talking to my dad about this and
and my dad really has um
i don't get emotional i'll try not to
but i think he's just uh opened up over
the last couple years
and uh it's nice to see and um you know
i you know and i've never heard my dad i
mean he's always he's six foot five
big dude loves hawk he loves sports work
hard never missed a day in his life you
know was
you know he was you just never you know
and here's me who always falls apart and
just
you know so we're kind of opposites in
most ways
but after all these years she was really
sick and in the hospital and
and this time was different this time
you know
she passed she passed away and um
it was like uh a couple nights ago
and uh you know
for many years i just thought it'd be
just best for everyone if she did pass
that's sort of like i i
and i and i and i say that in the in a
way that
you don't want her to suffer i'm tired
of seeing you know
them suffer and i thought you know
it just it would just be better and you
sort of like
and and by the way i i live across the
country i don't see my dad very often
once a year once every other year and
then
she's been at a hospital that's outside
of new york and so when i go there for
two days
occasionally i would see her but you
know it's not like i had this
and it's hard to have a relationship
with um
with her you see her and it's nice and
you make her smile and
whatever and um but anyway
you know she when she passed you think
that
okay this is it's for the better and you
and i do still believe that i
i think that now long story short
long story longer my dad i talked to him
and it crushed me
i i've never heard my dad cry ever
he's 68 never
have seen any kind of like emotion like
that i'm sure you know i know he does
like he you know he told me about when
his dog passed and
he held the dog in his arms but
so he held her in her arms to her last
breath little leah
and you know stay with her and and
inconsolable like
you know these nurses at this hospital
and i want to get their names and i want
to send them something
and and contact them because boy
these these nurses who
not only witness death and sickness
every day but
children there's nothing the only thing
worse than sickness and death is when
it's
with a child when kids are suffering
there's nothing worse than that and
after their 12 hour shifts they stayed
with my father
and he stayed with the baby for another
hour or so and
um he just you know he was he was there
for probably 17 hours
until she passed and
i got a call on my home phone and it
says eric i still have a [ __ ] home
phone ryan i still have a [ __ ] home
phone
i don't care [ __ ] off and uh eric
rosenbaum calling my brother and i go
right when i heard that
i thought leah had passed i just knew it
because hey
my brother doesn't really call me all
that often it's usually a text
and it was my home phone so he must i
always have my ringer off i don't have
my
that's the one thing i do is i don't
keep my phone on so unless i see the
phone ringing
i'm not answering because i don't hear
and so
he goes hey and i knew it and he says
dad's awful and i was like yeah yeah
and i called my father and it was just
horrible horrible i just started crying
he was crying i was like
oh what's happening it just was like so
an emotion that i hadn't seen or
heard and it was just so visceral and
and thankfully you know over the next
day
um you know he's he's keeping busy and
getting all these things together and i
think that you know
he's he's managing i think um
you know he's going through it it's
horrible but so
when i say bad things come in three
you're like okay
you know and they progressively got
worse these three things i mean you
couldn't
um so anyway it's been tough and i just
wanted to share with everybody and
um you know i just uh
this episode i just wanted to
acknowledge my sister
liam may man i'm not gonna do it i'm not
gonna
get all teared up here but um you know
when she was born i didn't know what to
do because my dad was just
uh you know they were beside themselves
they have this kid who is
terminally ill from the get-go so all i
could think of was
i'm gonna get her name tattooed on my
arms that's what i'll do
just as a i don't know what to say here
look i did this
so i got her name leah and me on the
other arm
it's so funny too because you know years
ago when i i'd be at like some
club or you know back 15 years ago i
went into a club
probably 20 years ago now i was 50 about
15 years ago the last time i went to a
club or a bar or whatever and you
meet a girl and she's like oh what are
your tattoos i'm like the women in my
life
like really i go yeah that's my
grandma's my other grandma that's my
sister
oh that's sweet but um
so i just want to say that you know i'm
really really
sorry and uh dad i love you
i don't think he's listening to the
podcast i think i told him not to
because i get kind of personal and i
just was like you know you don't need to
listen to that and um
but i just wanted to kind of say that
you know
you know throw my love out there and
and just i hope i know that she's in a
better place and um
you know i just know that a lot of
people you know people lose
children people lose you see it on
facebook all the time i lost my dad
today or this is the 10th
anniversary of so-and-so's death and you
just see it and it become kind of
becomes numb
right we see it and it's not like we
don't care but if we cared about every
one of them we would go insane because
and it you know and then all of a sudden
now it's you
know it's you now you have you know and
and i think i just feel
bad as bad as i feel um
you know i just really i have no idea
what it's like to lose a child
no no idea and i think that i told him
yesterday i said i think that this is
the first time you're actually grieving
like all these years you've been holding
on to and it's been
horrible but now it's this release like
this is a
this is finality you know so yeah
[ __ ] man i know you know it's i just
wanted to share it because i just felt
like it was important and uh
it is what it is and i know that you
know this show it's uh we have fun and
we have laughs and
the great interviews and i want to thank
everybody for listening i say it all the
time but
if you're a new listener and you're
hanging out here and you're like i just
want to hear jared i just want to hear
jared and maybe you're not even
listening to the intro maybe just go
right into jared
but if you are listening to this um and
you listen to jensen
um and you love supernatural i hope that
if you like the interviews enough
you'll stick around and you'll just
listen to because i think you'll learn
something i know i do i think ryan does
i think all my
patrons out there you know we learn
something from people it's not like oh
this big gas dog i just want to hear
what he has to say i think you'll be
surprised by people you don't know
because i am i don't know these people
that well or at all and then i meet them
and i learn something from them and
i hope that you enjoy the show and you
keep tuning in and
a big shout out to uh westwood one
again for supporting the show they just
bought the show and
you know they're doing a great job and
um as you can hear we have some sponsors
this is this is fantastic ryan
we've got some sponsors uh content yeah
but thank you guys
and uh again shout out to all the
patrons
we just did a big zoom every couple
months i zoom with all the
well i have the you know there's
different tiers of patrons and so
um and if you don't know what patreon is
just go to patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
or whatever and look for inside of you
and it supports the podcast in other
ways and you get
inside of me episodes where people ask
questions patrons and what else is on
there
uh bonus episodes and um i do like these
youtube online
request lines where the patrons ask you
know play this song and
it's just a lot of fun and uh [ __ ]
talking where you get to ask
guest questions and um just a lot of
other
fun stuff on there it's a big community
a lot people become friends
um also you know it's funny i wanted to
shout out i don't even have to do this
but you know i love this guy
brandenburg i'm gonna say brandenburg
he's got this
uh he has a coffee shop named after his
mom who passed away peggy
and um it's peggy's coffeehouse.com
i just wanted to say hey if you want
some great coffee it really is amazing
and many of the patrons on there like
raj
and uh i think marissa and nico they
they all
they get tons of coffee from robert
brandenburg
at peggy's coffeehouse.com so they're so
supportive and um
it's a little mom-pop place uh one last
thing about the
my dog that's funny cause i was like you
know maybe i'll taxidermy irv
i was kidding of course you know it's
like i don't wanna and then i thought
huh why aren't my friends coming over
anymore it's like well you
taxi germany's your dog no one wants to
come over and
see that [ __ ] but it love dear family
um thank you so sorry thank you thanks
it's it's weird because you did sort of
talk about getting emotional
with your dad on this episode and it's
uh about the same thing
so and inadvertently i guess
inadvertently this is just sort of a
terrible terrible coincidence but wow
so anyway guys again thank you please
support please subscribe i notice on
on video if you're watching on video or
subscribers are getting larger and you
could download on apple
of course apple podcasts and spotify
and all that stuff and our handles if
you want to leave messages
are at insideepodcast on instagram and
facebook and at insideipod i believe on
twitter
i'm doing a virtual con coming up zooms
with me and welling and all that stuff
and uh you find me on that cameo isn't
that cameo just a lot of fun
uh also a reminder if you like any merch
or you want any merch we got great mugs
and autographed mugs inside of you
mugs they're amazing i just got a new
shipment because the last one sold out
available on the inside of you online
store new t-shirts ladies v-neck
fitted shirts and sweatshirts and
there's left on laurel
my old band it's like there's some
albums and cds left
and some hats inside of you hats
and also uh towels little beach towels i
love these
i don't even care if anybody buys them i
want these beach towels around my house
it's weird yes inside of you towels so
what
tough [ __ ] uh also rosenbaum.com
my my band my buddy rob my partner in
crime
we do all the stages we have a uh just
one shirt available in there it's really
cool
rosenbaumandanson.com
rosenbaumanndanson.com
and there's that shirt it's really cool
and there's not many so
get them while they're hot thank you to
all the patrons thank you to
or the patrons thank you for everyone
that's listening
love to my family love to uh little leah
and my dad and um
stay strong and uh this this interview i
i loved because
you know these guys have been on the
show forever and jared
jensen opened up but jared really
talks about a few things that you're
like i guess i don't talk about this
and uh i hope you'd appreciate that he's
so open and
honest and you know we're all flawed
just remember that we're all flawed we
all make mistakes and when you could
actually talk about it and go
hey this is what i did and i'm not proud
of it and i'm not doing this anymore
i think if you judge people based on the
things they've done
and not weigh in all the good they've
done
you know people do [ __ ] up people do say
the wrong [ __ ] people do
but to lambast them or to
not give them a second chance and by the
way i don't think he did anything that
that wrong
i'm just saying there's there's in
general people
um and sometimes people on podcasts
guests will say
hey rosie can you cut that and i do but
when they
don't when they say hell i want people
to hear it i want people to hear my side
of the story or i want to
i think it's just uh it's just nice to
hear because
i mean we're not perfect i'm sure i mean
there's so much
i i [ __ ] up constantly i think you guys
know that i am a [ __ ] up
all right this is this is a great
episode you're gonna love it
and uh thanks for uh thanks for all the
support and love
and um let's get inside of jared
pedolecki it's my
point of view you're listening to
inside of you with michael rose
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
what's the word man where are you at i'm
in my house go figure i'm in my house i
don't leave this house
often yeah where are you you're in
vancouver i'm in my apartment
vancouver um was this a temp apartment
or something you've had for a long time
oh i mean when we uh when we are we
starting you want to start
i mean this is it's always starting i
mean okay all right
yeah um i i'm in my apartment where i
got it
so i have this pretty awesome apartment
in vancouver that's been my home away
from home
but it started out as a temp apartment
the uh the owner landlord who's a friend
of mine
um my friend marshall uh he
his prior tenant was leaving and he was
like well i was gonna move back
but he has a place up in pemberton or
whistler he's like well you know
i thought this was season
ship was we were pregnant chef so this
would have been 2013.
and i was like listen man you know like
we're in season six or seven whatever it
was
i i might need it for another year maybe
two years he's like that's fine
you know uh that's good so fast forward
what eight years later seven years later
and uh you know he's he's the best guy
on the planet he's the nicest guy
um and he's sort of like all right well
you need to re-up re-up
and so it became uh it became kind of
a more permanent uh
living situation but it's still i mean
i'm in my uh
let's do this i'm in my uh
master bedroom in my apartment but i'm
actually i'm legitimately in a sauna
blanket
i wanted to i was just watching that i
was like what is he is that an ice pack
you've got a sauna blanket
yeah i have a by the way this is no i
have no affiliation with them
no like plugs but there's a there's an
infrared sauna blanket from higher dose
but i heard uh ben greenfield uh
read his books i heard him on a rogan
podcast
he's like a biohacker and i'm a big fan
of his
but he uh he talked about this infrared
sauna blanket and so jen and i
are lucky enough to have an infrared
sauna at our home in austin
and so i travel with this so i i roll it
up in a suitcase
and then you know if we're doing a
convention or something in chicago we're
flipping vancouver
i'll bring this and i'll get to wherever
i am check out the hotel
and i'll plug this in and preheat it up
um
so what to what does this tell you the
temperature all right well you're about
to see my bedroom
uh so i have my well it won't be your
bedroom for long
yeah i think another two weeks so you
just plug it in
plug it in plug it in it just goes
through the wall and plugs into the
blanket are you naked under there under
that
i'm not so you can't be naked because
it gets hot right so i'm wearing socks i
have a towel
but i put my feet in socks and
sweatpants and uh
a little underwear is it just filled
with sweat at the end
it's pretty gnarly yeah it's pretty but
you open it up and you
dry it off with a wet wipe or whatever i
mean like wet wipes are hard to find
these days
because of cobit um so i just kind of
wash it down but i'm closed so you don't
want your skin
touching the uh and usually you go full
cocoon
like i'm a full category right about to
you know
come into my own as a butterfly but um
i love that you're blanket sauna while
we're talking
why wouldn't you is it by the way does
it does the lethargy kick in
are you tired after or does it
invigorate you did you
need a shower after i think it depends i
mean i do shower after but these days
i mean by the way remember that when
apples and i flew up here
on august 2nd we had a quarantine in our
apartments for two weeks
yeah so like no going into the hallway
and it's really funny because we flew in
and the customs agents we saw
they were like listen because he brought
his dog up i brought my dog up
and they were like well listen when you
walk your dogs just be very careful you
know the dogs can't socialize can dogs
dogs can be carriers um and we apples
and i had read through the
regulations restrictions you know a
dozen times so we're like
wait when we walk our dogs they're like
yeah just just be careful you know we
don't really have
kobe 19 here in canada yet and we're
trying to keep it from coming in
like we get it we get it and so we told
our production coordinator
uh fisher we were like hey man the
customs agents
seem to think that we can walk our dogs
when you look into it
he was like yeah i'll look into it and
they're like listen you can
but well you can't by the
by the rule of the law you cannot leave
i couldn't go to my hallway i couldn't
go my garbage uh
is down the elevator and so i wasn't
allowed to do that
luckily i had a dog walker who came
twice a day for my dog
and she would drop it off and she'd be
like yeah that's fine and so i'd have
all this garbage
and um she would come by and go like
yeah cool i'll drop it off on the way
long story short we uh it was sort of
one of those situations where we thought
well some people think we can go outside
some don't
i don't want to risk it and the the fine
i think
the fine wasn't enormous it wasn't like
a million dollar fine if you were caught
outside
it was it was you know i don't want to
pay the fine but
the bigger problem was we got here on
august 2nd
which was a sunday we had a quarantine
for two weeks
till august 16th sunday night and then
film on tuesday
so if august 5th or whatever that
tuesday or wednesday was
i decided to take my garbage out and an
agent happened to be there
they would have restarted quarantine we
sort of you know messed up supernatural
schedule
and pushed everything another four days
five days
god forbid you know you take your dog
out to pee at midnight and there happens
to be an agent there going like hey
you're supposed to be quarantining uh
you know
so you didn't do it i didn't no i didn't
leave you didn't leave
i can't i'm i mean i just can't even ima
i can't i in my house i
i go outside i can do things like what
day is it like i watch that show alone
where they're alone for like
77 days i had the guy jordan i had
jordan jonas on the show who won season
six
yes dude amazing dude he'll love him
yeah jordan jonas man season six one he
not only is he awesome but he's like
yeah man i do these little things these
excursions and i teach people survival
if you want your friends to come out i
go
if i flew you out here with some friends
would you do it he goes heck yeah man
let's just find a place i'll come out
with you and your buddies
by the way since i got here uh on august
2nd i keep on saying that date
but my my genevieve and our kids
have been watching alone and so they're
like and i was like well i know who wins
like
don't say it don't say that don't say
dad somebody killed a raccoon
and a tasmanian devil ate it or a
wolverine or whatever and i'm like well
i'm just gonna
just don't even say it's just it's
mesmerizing too and like you know
yeah and i'm not we can get into that
but it's harder though by the way
my my dog showed up i got to give a
shout out to coda cotto what's up
buddy oh my gosh look at the little paw
oh my god that is the cutest little
shepherd that's a full shepherd huh
he is yeah so my dog uh my
i had a i had a shepherd mix that i got
from uh
the spca in los angeles when i was doing
gilmore girls
in between scenes i you know being a
guest star on gilmore girls like number
eight on the call sheet they were like
okay here you are we need your work at
four a.m
and then you'll you'll finish that scene
around like 10 a.m and then we need you
back at 8pm
i was like all right and so i went to
the spca on sherman way
i lived on fulton at the time right up
the block from casa vega
and so i just went straight at fulton
took sherman way over to the spca
and got sadie and this was june 6 2003
when she was a rescue wow shepherd like
really classic coloring the brown the
black nose
uh anyways so i got sadie and then last
january
she was supposed to be or she would have
made it to 16 in march
and then in january it was just that
time i mean she was a
uh she's an awesome dog but she also
i mean i i got her season two of gilmore
girls
and had her for three more seasons of
gilmore girls then i had her for
14 seasons supernatural she went to new
york with me when i shot with riley
uh new york minute she went to uh
virginia with me your best friend your
best friend pretty much she's my girl
man like i
i was single when i got her and she was
around for everything how hard is it
listen because i almost
i was as close as you can come to losing
my dog last week
on saturday 12 years rescue best friend
irv
and i lost my grandfather urban november
named my dog
irv and he was like what are you naming
the dogger for i'm still alive
at the time anyway so erv my dog also
had this infection
almost died 106 degree temperature
somehow turned it around the best
doctors and like i still got him and
he's in the other room and he's like
on a lot of pills and he's not in any
pain i wouldn't i'm not one of those
owners who
uh would let him suffer just because i
want him alive if he was suffering
i'm sorry as hard as it as it would be i
would
put him to sleep but he's doing better
but how hard when
when sadie passed how hard was that for
you i know sadie was 16 and old but like
what wouldn't
it was the worst man but you know what
with are you saying earth or
irv like irving no way yeah so
you'll know herb will let you know you
know that's my that was my thing with
sadie is she was
she had lost her hips her back hips a
little bit and i had this harness
that we had bought and you would kind of
like hold her back hips
and then the leash was attached to her
like a harness on her chest
and so she couldn't pee she couldn't
poop she couldn't get it out at night
but when i woke up and got to the living
room here at the apartment
she looked at me like what are we doing
and so she wasn't in
pain and then and that was
that that was for a good
i don't know man like four or five
months where i was like well am i being
an [ __ ] because i'm so
deeply in love with this thing attached
to this dog like am i being a jerk
like i i need to let her go to the next
world with dignity
and you know her own integrity and um
and then one day it just kind of like
she just kind of like one day i went
walk to the living room
emotional i'm already emotional now with
the seasoning too man i'm thinking about
it right now
yeah but um one day i kind of got up and
she was
my couch here in the living room i had
to get furniture
free pads like furniture probably too
that's what i have for her yeah he's
having problems walking
i put him on the couch and so at night i
would lift her up on the couch
because she couldn't hold her weight
facilities no she didn't
facilities yeah yeah that's it so i was
like well um
all right like i and she was really
embarrassed by it like she was still
mentally there
and then one day like every day i would
get up and she'd kind of like
wrench her neck around she couldn't move
uh her hips
but she wrench her neck around to look
at me like where are we going dad where
are we going
and then one day she kind of looked at
me like hey buddy i'm ready
um yeah there we go uh
and so that lasted for like three or
four days at first i was like well maybe
she didn't sleep or something
and then probably three or four days uh
same thing and i was like okay like i'm
gonna let her go
chase cars in the sky or squirrels in
the sky or something
that was hard it was real hard did you
did you take her in were you in there
because some people will tell me
you don't want to you don't want to be
in there and then some people say you
want to be there for the last
you were there you want to be there yeah
you do
um oh you just want to tell irv like hey
dude
you've been the best man like my life is
better
so many people's lives are better
because you're part of it and so i did i
have it moment with sadie
um and my friend kelly was there who uh
kelly's our onset
uh wardrobe and she's become a dear
friend and you know it is
when you're shooting you they're like
hey here's your trailer
and set is a 20 minute drive away and
we're daylight dependent and so
kelly way back in season one she'd be
like hey do you want me to take stadium
for a pee
break when you're on set i was like i
would love that and so then it became
then sadie became like our dog um and so
when i was on set
kelly would take her when i flew home to
austin to see genevieve and the kids
she'd go to kelly's house like sadie
girl man i mean i know i was her dad
or whatever but as soon as kelly walked
in the room sadie was like
kelly's here kelly's here so anyways
kelly and i were there
and we let her kind of go off um
yeah it was really tough man i'm sorry
about even irv
uh i know yet but when it happens it was
a it was really tough
time i don't know if it was a month or
two or whatever
but there was a day when i woke up and i
was done with crying
and kind of moping and i was like you
know what man my life is so much better
so many people's lives are so much
better because
sadie was in it so and now it's just
been smiles
but i tell ya i can just i could just
hear in that story you can just tell
how much you love that dog it's just
it's so obvious
like you know some people say oh yeah i
was good like just i could just tell
it's so
visual it's so and by the way by the way
i mean that i didn't need to explain
with me she's still with me yeah
always and i i didn't expect every time
i talked to my new dog and
you know what i mean yeah oh yeah for
sure i mean uh
and i look i didn't even expect to talk
about the dog and all this stuff but hey
i love hearing it it's
it's a it's a real thing and you know
when when you're in
back to you you're being in your place
you're supernatural you're you're in the
last episode at this point right now
we started it uh friday so today sunday
we started it two days ago
yeah because you made you posted you
said a post it was like a really nice
post right
yeah you said something uh as i head out
to the first day on my last season
finale
i can't help but be incredibly grateful
for all that supernatural in the spnf
family spnf spn family
how much they mean to me it's been an
incredible journey to say the least i
for one am hoping that supernatural
never dies what did you mean by that
for which part that was a long sentence
i mean the part where you hope
supernatural never dies
you hope just hang on hang on is it a i
just want it to go on forever in terms
of the fans will always remember in 30
years from now when i walk into it you
know
oh my supernatural and it will just
always be in people's minds and and
new to new generations is it that or is
it be
i'd like to come back and do a
supernatural movie or maybe we'll do
another season someday who
knows or is it a combination of both uh
yes yes yes and yes
um yeah it was a difficult
i knew i wanted to kind of send
something and not even for me like i'm
not a big
i'm not a big poster guy a
posting on social media kind of guy
right like i just lose track it's not
that i don't i think there's a lot of
value in social media like
i i'd be lying if i didn't say i flipped
through instagram and
and twitter or whatever during takes
um i just don't think about it it's not
something i
i think i i don't know i'm trying to
psychoanalyze myself no i
let me let me analyze you because i i by
just by knowing you a little
i could see that you're like you're a
family guy you get distracted by life
and nature and things and yeah and just
like like living you're more in the
present than you are
always on your phone where someone like
me lately i've been like you know i'm on
the phone i'm this and that and i'm
trying
hence why i watched alone and cry at
every season
and i call i email jordan after i direct
message him this is why it works
sometimes you direct message people
they're like [ __ ] off or they don't
respond
sometimes you go because hey i have a
podcast that i love and i think you know
people
it's an interesting and he immediately
goes man i love i'd love to be on the
show
that's amazing yeah man hey cool i'm a
big fan of his me too
and like a lot of people don't know but
look if you're listening to us listen to
the jordan jonas episode
it's it's great he's a great guy he's
got a big heart and then wait to hear
his story i'm sure you know some of it
but
anyway well let's talk about i promise
you this man as soon as we hang up i'm
going to listen to it oh you'll love it
yeah yeah
he's hilarious yeah yeah good good i
think you know what's funny is that
i'm gonna push back just because
i don't disagree with you but i'm trying
to i'm trying to hash out my own
feelings but you were saying that you
know you
you lived in the moment for a while i
want to connect more that's what i'm
trying to do i want to connect more and
more
here's what i'll offer and here's what
i'm trying to deal with right now
you know saying goodbye to a friend of
15 years
the show you know my character sam like
i know so well i was
i was i've never gone i'm going from
tangent a little bit
i've never gone five months without
playing sam winchester not since i was
22 years old and i'm 38 now with a wife
and three kids
um and gray hairs they have to scratch
out with a comb
uh very humbling but i i would say this
man like
i think as actors hey and you know this
more than anybody
when they say okay rolling action
you have to be in the moment you have to
you can't think about like oh did i lock
my door
oh uh i should have called my friend oh
my god my
agent uh i was supposed to call him uh
five minutes ago
oh my taxes are due you have to live
right there in the moment
and i think it sounds like and having
known you for a while
you're that kind of person anyways so
that's your nature but also your nurture
right here i mean michael rosenbaum on
sunday
at 11 19 uh
pacific time you have a thousand things
you could be doing if you were just
laying in your bathtub
you have a you have a thousand you know
a thousand might be hyperbole or
something
one one thing you're like let's say
you have a dozen things that you could
be doing right like oh i gotta send this
text
my my three buddies text me when i was
asleep i gotta respond them all
um but now you're here with me and
you're with me and we're a thousand
miles away or whatever
on a computer but you're able to be
present and i think that's magical
there's a downside to that there's a
there's a second edge to that sword
right
where i'm really bad and you know this
and you've teased me and i think we've
teased each other
i don't answer phone calls i don't
respond to emails i don't respond to
texts
i get them and then i like go back to
set or i get him and then
pick my kid back up and jump in the pool
right and i'll get to it later i'll get
to it later i'll get to it later
so i feel like one of these things is
we're sort of blessed and cursed
by this idea that we are good
at living in the moment and i guess i'm
grateful for it i guess i've had to
become grateful for it because i don't
have another choice it is my nature it
is my nurture
um and so i don't know where i was
really going with this
uh other than to say um well about being
connected about being
why why you're on instagram thank you
yes so you're talking about your phone
and being on your phone
and i would say that you still connect
your phone i would i would argue
on your behalf that when you are on your
phone even if you're among
a million people uh there's a michael
buble song i used to listen to
season one sing it jared i was embracing
kayla i ain't gonna say it i don't wanna
i don't want people to tune out
but uh maybe surrounded by a million
people i still feel all alone
i want to go home now that i'm feeling
alone but the idea that
yeah yeah you're a singer uh the idea
that you can be
in a in the most crowded room and still
be in your head
the idea that you can have a million
things to do and still choose to get on
your phone
it's part escapism i assume i don't know
i'm still learning
um but i think there's some magic also
too i'm going to commit
i'm on my phone i'm not going to send
just like smiley face emoji
i'm going to write something yeah like
hey my buddy texted me
i'm going to i'm going to uh process
that i'm going to take it in
i'm going to think of what i need to say
and i'm going to move forward so i think
[Music]
15 years yeah i i hear what you're
saying
but you know to me do you know what
connection is
this is why i think i love the podcast
so much
honestly i love doing this because i put
these things
on and i've said it before but i am
zoned in i'm listening and i'm
enjoying and i'm not really distracted
i'm i'm listening to
an old friend and hearing a story about
his dog and like
i'm really connecting like to me this is
this is
maybe this is a weird way of me being
able to connect to people maybe i should
talk to my mom
on my podcast or my my my girlfriend i
don't have a girlfriend
but if i did
famously awful at checking my emails and
even worse at answering phone calls so
let's text this [ __ ]
i'm still at four seven no i'm just
kidding i one guy you looked up for a
second well he's not gonna read his
number but by the way i would have been
playing
i was gonna get my phone and be like
don't don't rosie what are you doing
inside of you is brought to you by
better help online counseling
uh you guys know these guys you guys
know these guys and so do i because
they're incredibly helpful that's why
they've been a sponsor for a while and i
think that
this is sort of the show that uh you
know a lot it allows people to
um sort of get comfortable and and
sort of come to terms with maybe the
fact that they need
therapy and that they can do it in a
private
way if you think you might be depressed
or anxious or
uh you're dealing with family matters or
grieving
in the last few weeks i know i know what
this this is about if you've been
listening to the show then you know that
uh
i kind of know what i'm talking about
but you could talk with your counselor
in a private online environment at your
own convenience
from wherever you're comfortable better
help counselors have expertise in a
broad range of areas i talked about
anxiety but there's so much more uh
people deal with trauma and
anger and lgbt matters
self-esteem better helping give you
access to help that may not be available
in your area
you just fill out a questionnaire to
help assess your specific needs
and you get matched up with your
counselor in under 48 hours
easily schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages
everything you share is confidential
and if for any reason you're unhappy
with your counselor guess what you know
you just request a new one
at no additional charge at any time i
think that's
pretty easy and pretty cool join the
million plus people taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced better help counselor
in fact so many people have been using
better help they're currently recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
betterhelp is an affordable option and
our listeners get 10 off your first
month
with the discount code inside
get started today at betterhelp.com
slash
inside that's better h-e-l-p
dot com slash inside
talk to a therapist online and get some
help
inside of you is brought to you by quip
these guys are unbelievable first of all
the toothbrush is
fantastic and i love the price and
you know what they're doing now they're
rewarding you for brushing your teeth
you use their toothbrush it connects to
the bluetooth on an app
and it tells you it monitors how much
you're brushing all this
and you start to get points gift cards
other things
for brushing your teeth when have you
ever in your life been rewarded
for brushing your teeth never and i
think i deserve it
so you're a brusher what brusher well
then you know damn it you need to
i hope you can get a quip i'm going to
try and get quip to get you equipped
so you're equipped then you can start
getting rewarded because ryan you
deserve to be rewarded we all
deserve it damn right the quip smart
brush for adults and kids connects to
the quip
app with bluetooth track when and how
well you brush get tips and coaching to
improve your habits earn
points for daily brushing and bonus
points for completing the challenges
like streaks
redeem for awards like free products
gift cards and discounts from quip
and partners and if you already have
equip upgrade it with a smart motor and
keep the features you know and love
sensitive sonic vibrations two minute
timer with 30 second pulses for a guided
clean
slim lightweight and sleek with no wires
or bulky charger to weigh you down
multi-use travel cover that doubles as a
mirror mount for less clutter
beyond the brush quip has everything you
need to build a complete
routine mint or watermelon toothpaste
with anti-cavity ingredients for strong
healthy teeth
plus you can get brush heads toothpaste
floss refills delivered from
five dollars and shipping is free how
smart is that
join over five million mouths who use
quip and save hundreds compared to other
bluetooth brushes
when you get equipped smart brush for
just 45 dollars
start getting rewards for brushing your
teeth today and go to getquip.com
you right now to get your first refill
free that's your first refill free at
get quip dot com
slash you spelled g-e-t-q-u-i-p
dot com slash y-o-u quip
better oral health made simple and
rewarding
dude so you know being up there back to
this i mean we're all over the place in
a good way because i like this i like it
it people you know some people have said
the conversations just seem like two
guys are having a conversation or you're
having a conversation with a
woman whatever it's just like off the
cuff and it is i know
enough about you and we have a
familiarity but
you know i'm also interested in like
i personally gives me an anxiety attack
thinking about being in my apartment for
two weeks without going back to that
without being able to take the garbage
out without going to
order food without or going to get food
or walking my dog
so what day do you start to go it hit me
i'm [ __ ] i'm getting anxiety i'm
getting no i'm going down a spiral i
can't
or were you fine you know what man i
having never
done it before we flew up here
i was panicked because i also i do have
clinical anxiety and i have
for a large part of my adult life
um and i was like i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be a mess which is also
why i was happy to have my buddy yeah
so oh it's amazing but i
you know day
day four or five i was like i could do
this forever
i mean if i didn't miss my friends and
my family i mean it man
and i didn't know i was terrified i was
mortified we had called friends that
were here and they were like hey will
you put some canned chili
like like i was going to war it was like
people
was in my good parents i was so panicked
and then also i was with my kids eight
six and three and my wife
and they were concerned they were like
you can be all right and she don't want
us to go
i was like i'm good i'm good man i'm
good baby i love you
we'll facetime it how often do you talk
to your family do you talk to them three
times a day or just once or what
i guess depends on the day i mean i just
lived with them for five months
you know from march 13th to uh august
2nd to be honest they're not going to
listen to this you were ready to get the
f out
you needed a little break daddy needed
to go to work no and by the way that's
not even
that's not a secret like a large part
it's more difficult i say this i mean
this will give me a perfect opportunity
to
to compliment my wife who's just a
[ __ ] stallion man like she just does
so much
and you know i i'm used to i'm like well
baby i have
to film and it's a stunt scene and an
emotional scene i have to get there
and i'm like yeah i'm a badass and then
i get home and my job is like take out
the garbage
i'm like i can't take out the garbage
like i have to blah blah and then you
realize like holy [ __ ] like she has no
time for herself and still does
the world's best job i mean i'm way out
of my league and this is gonna sound
like
i'm being as honest as humanly possible
uh i'm out of my league and seeing her
in her element and getting there
in march so uh march 12th
we filmed our last day
pseudo last day of season 15 because
march 13th
is when all like when justin trudeau and
the prime minister
was gonna make his speech and they're
like oh they're gonna shut down the
border
get home and so friday the 13th uh
a plug for my movie friday 13th from
12th yeah
hello so we end up getting sent home on
friday 13th of march
and you know i got home and i just done
you know we had a convention in vegas
the weekend before
uh i had run the austin marathon the
weekend before that or maybe two weeks
either way
it had been like busy busy busy give me
a job give me a job and then i was like
okay you're home
i was like what do i do put me to work
and jen's like you know make sure the
kids don't fight
um you know we don't give them snacks at
this time or that time
uh they're gonna and i was like okay and
i was looking around watching her do
what she does and i was like holy
mother she's got a routine she's got it
down she knows exactly what's going on
down
and also as you know from acting for
decades plus
it's like well okay i need i need 10
minutes in my trailer
like you don't get that when three kids
are running around could you imagine
you're just like
what shep uh yeah tom is eight shep is
six
odette is three chef i'm going to my
trailer
no you're knocked out what happens he
goes okay i'm gonna come with you
and you're not really like no you will
not come with me i just want to sit
there and cry for five minutes and then
get back to it
so they and they want to be around
they're like dad is home and so then i
was like
the new toy i was like wait dad is home
and
you know you have uh three two-legged
alarm clocks that are jumping on you
and waking up
and at work even if i think the first
day back to work we had an exterior
daylight shot
and so i think our pickup was like 4 45
a.m or something because it's still
summer hours
so it's bright in vancouver at 6 30 so
they're like we need you ready by
six so that we can go straight to
filming 6 30 because the sun goes down
we lose the location and i'm like okay
that's going to suck
but i'll nap at lunch there's no napping
at lunch when you've got a bunch of kids
running around so to see genevieve do
dude you know what's funny i when i have
a friend
come over like every christmas i have
like a couple of my friends with
their families and my friends yeah you
know single guy has everybody over the
house
yeah yeah and we and the kids are there
and i love the kids
but when they leave after like four
hours i'm like yeah
they could they have to they could and
it's always when you're dealing with
other kids you're like oh my god this
kid's so cute or
this is so cute i could do and you're
dealing with an hour you're like good i
can walk away now
but so kudos to your wife uncle man
that's called
uncle yes and by the way but your wife
and
all the women out there or stay-at-home
dads or whatever it is
i'm i i'm telling i'm not saying this to
go oh look like i'm just support
it is so obvious that women have it or
men
or stay-at-home dads you're watching the
kids there's no job harder
there's no effing job harder i see it
last night i was in a zoom call we did a
music i stage it
so i play music for yeah i do i'm we're
making a new album i'm making about
my uh like guitars i loved your last one
so thank dude
thanks get it on no but uh
uh well so we're there and we're on his
i'm on a zoom with a couple people
because they
they won or whatever and they're on
there and the woman's at two in the
morning in england she's just
like she has her baby who's crying i'm
like and i'm just like holy [ __ ]
it was i think it was carly shout out to
carly i think it was carly
but anyway holy [ __ ] like like
if when you're married you know someone
works someone they both work
i don't for it's so terrifying i look at
my parents and how they did it and like
you know i always say i've come to
a conclusion i've worked my ass off in
therapy
and i you know what hey i love you guys
you did the best that you could
i'm not saying you were the best parents
by
far yeah but you did the best that you
could or you knew how to do but
for all those parents out there i i just
like yeah your wife i i
it's that's terrifying it's so hard it's
like you got three kids bouncing around
you got to be on tr i would have an
anxiety attack because i'm like an ocd
like i'd want to know where everybody is
don't
don't you can't put that there well put
that down you're gonna hurt yourself i
always would think someone's gonna
start a fire or something yeah and you
also feel like well i i feel like
you as an adult you know you're like
okay well i see them doing something
wrong
i better correct them every single time
forgetting like hey they're three
they're figuring [ __ ] out like don't
don't terrorize them
here's something funny talk about
therapy and talking about uh your
parents being the best of the worst
is i i've seen a psychiatrist have been
very public and i suggest it and
recommend it to every human being on the
planet
and without getting too much detail i
had a conversation my psychiatrist
doesn't talk a lot
like he more forces me to suss it out
myself and to admit things to myself
before suggesting them you know um and
one time
so he doesn't speak a whole lot and then
one time i'm on his couch and i'm kind
of
pontificating and i was like i'm just
really afraid
i'm gonna [ __ ] up my kids and he goes oh
you will
and hey he talked beale's like
that's not what
it was so comforting because we went
into it then he's like you know what if
you're the worst parent on the planet
it's pretty obvious how you'll you know
affect them in negative ways
in the future and if you're but people
don't think about this if you're the
best parent on the planet
then in some sense they live in your
shadow and they go like i'm not
i can't make my parents happy because
they were so
they did the best they could dude
um you know my parents my mom's birthday
was yesterday happy birthday mom
uh but um you know they they went and
met for a social distance
uh there's a great place called salt
lake bbq and i love going there it's
just like
halfway between san antonio my parents
live where i grew up and austin where i
live my brother lives and our families
um and they met for a social distance uh
kind of birthday brunch
and um you know they're they're they're
great i was
enormously blessed but i've been said no
matter who's in your life if someone's
in that position
in your life they're going to be some
things that if you have the wherewithal
to look into it and to have professional
help to look into
the way you were raised the way you grew
up your thought processes
then you're like oh wow i guess i
i guess i do like here's something funny
um my buddy was asking me about the
difference between a psychologist and
psychiatrist
and i say this with no medical training
just with
uh you know experience with
psychologists and psychiatrists
and i was like so the best way and this
was on the moment i'm really proud of
myself even though it's probably
outrageously wrong
psychologist psychiatrist so
psychiatrists are more high ideal
psychologists are
very actionable so my analogy and again
maybe i'll get roasted but [ __ ] it i'm
gonna say it it's like a psychologist
goes
if you say if you say to your
psychologist like hey
um i go home at night and i eat a tub of
ice cream but i'm struggling to wait
then they'll say like hey well you know
what don't eat a cup of ice cream or buy
lower fat ice cream
or eat half a tub like separate it into
containers
it's very actionable it's very make your
bed right it's very take the stairs
okay don't don't drive around for five
minutes looking for a close parking spot
park at the fir park at the farthest
part you can't walk what does a
psychiatrist say
so like a psychiatrist if you're like
hey i go home i get some ice cream
they'll be like why like why do you want
the ice cream
were you rewarded as a child with uh
desserts you know if you got good grades
would you get
uh an ice cream date or a plate of
nachos or some cookies
like is it even as an adult you don't
realize that i mean i'm 38 with three
kids of my own
and part of me i love candy i think
everybody i know knows that
i love candy i hate candy and i remember
like candy to me
is going to theme parks and here my dad
goes like here's two bucks
and so i go to the the arcade and get a
bunch of tokens on foosball or skee-ball
or whatever
um and because i know if you candy i l
so for me like candy is a reward
right and my buddy my new buddy keegan
allen who's playing my brother in walker
is uh he's he's very right and i tease
him all the time
he's very like dude don't do sugar like
sugar will mess you up and i'm like
fine i'm gonna go have a snickers or
whatever it is i don't like chocolate
but i'll have some sour patch kids
but for me sugar and nachos
or whatever is a treat because we
couldn't really afford it growing up
like hey here's all the barbecue and
tech specs in the world
but you know we get good grades we win a
basketball game it's like hey i'm gonna
make some cookies
here's some ice cream and so i have this
so the psychologist is like well
if you're struggling with weight take
the stairs
park far away don't eat a full gallon of
ice cream psychiatrist
is like just like why do you think
you're doing that right
you know you know what i say i always
just thought the difference was because
i have a psychiatrist and a psychologist
but
you know it's like i talk to him like
every every week or but it's like you
know intermittent i would say
intermittent but i try to
i need to call them that's what i'm
saying do it so my psychiatrist
psychologist sits there and she's
amazing sandy she's been on the show i
had her on the show she's amazing and
she'll talk
she is so i mean and you're right a good
one will sit there and go
okay well um well why do you why
it was it was different because my
psychologist she was always like well
she's also a
behavioralist behavior
i don't even know cbt what i don't maybe
not and
she will say you know she will talk
about things and why do you think that
happens well
why do you think you do that she it's
different where the psychiatrist is just
like
they can prescribe you drugs
psychologists can't psychiatrists can
prescribe drugs that's the big thing and
also the psychiatrist you ever notice
at least for me psychologist is an hour
meeting psychiatrist
15 minutes they just evaluate they're
like okay how's everything going okay
great i'm like
i heard about this drug gabapentin or
uh this uh choleshop riddle uh or this
uh bondrocketing
it really gives you is like it's like
well we could try that i mean
it's just so that's how i always think a
psychiatrist gets you the drug
psychologist kind of like
talks you through [ __ ] now i've i've
done a lot of when i'm here by the way i
love this conversation it really you
just all over the conversation well i
was just
and i was like well he didn't [ __ ]
call me no i was calling both of you
i know you don't know yeah if you don't
answer your phone
come on man it's true but i will say
this you're
encouraging me i'm just saying this
you're incredibly enjoyable
like while you were talking the other
minute you have like my energy
in a way because you're like excited you
want to talk about it and just i like it
it's easy i can just like talk to you
forever
so back to uh if you're in person i'd
kiss you with tongue writing i know well
uh covered kiss it'd be a six six it'd
be just like a
buffalo bill kiss or something i could
do that too
so did you have anxiety because look you
had obviously good parents you're saying
my i'm not you know my parents again
they tried the best they could but it
was just more of a thing where
my dad was like the kind of guy no
therapy
no emotions no never seen him cry
nothing and the other day i asked him
because you know
my half-sister uh he remarried and had a
daughter and she's been she's had this
chromosomal
defect for she's lived she's just she's
a trooper but she's like 15 and she's
incredibly like she's not gonna make it
she's not gonna and she should have like
passed
when she was born the fact that she's
lived this long and she's just not lived
a good life and it's always been you
know and she's been in hospital and
not for lack of they've done my parents
you know my mom my dad my my stepmom
they did
everything they could the best doctors
of it there was nothing
she there's nothing that could help this
disease it was just
and so he's been struggling for a long
time and it's been really hard but like
you know i said to him i said i've never
seen you cry i go you know blah blah
he goes i cry
and i just that was all he had to yeah i
know and i was just like it's sort of
like
for once in my life i feel like and i
know this is about you but this is
podcast about us
it's it's like my father it's like my
father and i after all these years
have sort of come to a place where
he respects i'm sort of like
you know i'm an entertainer i'm all over
the place i'm funny maybe
i do all these things i'm just way the
point is i'm different than him
and he's finally i finally feel like
he's accepting me for me
and and at the same time i'm sort of
doing the same thing but also watching
him
you know be more compassionate so
there's there's this appreciation so
that's all i'll say about that but
anxiety did you suffer anxiety your
whole life
i don't say suffer not anymore are you
on
medications for it i'm not um i
uh well not even not about
my point is is that i i do believe
uh in the power of uh
love self-fulfilling prophecies so
if i say to myself like i'm suffering
from depression i'm suffering from
anxiety i'm suffering from this
then i'm the victim and i can't do
anything about it if i say to myself hey
if i say myself this man for those two
weeks
in quarantine i suffered from anxiety i
i had a i have a garmin on my arm and it
tracks your steps i'd have 20 000 steps
someday in a three bedroom apartment
and i don't say suffer i [ __ ] hate
that word
um and here's my favorite saying pain is
mandatory
suffering is optional so you will deal
with pain
pain is is universal there's not a human
being on the planet whether they're born
a billionaire or born you know in
in the uh you know in a terrible
terrible situation pain is going to
happen you've dealt with pain
you will deal with pain i've dealt with
pain i will deal with pain it's my
choice whether or not to accept it
and try and deal with it or to allow it
to make me suffer
so suffering is my option so i don't
suffer from anxiety i've dealt with
anxiety
i have a relationship with anxiety but
these days
i i see it as a school bully and i deal
with it i love that
i love it jared i think it's it's so
important because i remember my
psychologist said yeah hey anxiety could
be here
anxiety's in the back seat right now
i've said this before says the backseat
but you're driving
so you can know it's there and you go
hey what's up now [ __ ] you i'm driving
right now
i know you're there but you don't you
don't get to drive this car
i feel like there's a podcast let's do
or something where somebody's talking
about
death in the same way and how they were
terrified mortified of death and their
mortality and the fact that
oh my god i'm not gonna be able to wake
up one day or
go for a walk and they were like and now
they've become
uh a welcome friend like they're in the
passenger seat and they'll say things
and they're that friend that you
disagree with
but you love them and you're like hey
you know death is telling you like hey
this is all going to end
this could be the last time you take a
right at a stop sign hey this could be
the last time you have a diet coke
maybe a piece of rib gets caught in your
throat and you either believe that
person and i've met a lot of people who
have had some pretty severe
who have dealt with not suffered who
have dealt with pretty severe
anxiety and depression and suicidal
thoughts
and i guess hold on hey quiet
is that your pup is that that's the
puppy
little cameo man hey he's like i heard
koda was on the podcast
well erv's also 90 deaf so the neighbors
probably think i'm screaming at him i go
get over here i can't hear i'm not
yelling at
him go ahead he's getting a whisper but
i guess i just try
when people are really dealing with it
in a big big way
there's some bit and i've used my own
life this isn't me
like proselytizing like well if you take
this pill or
practice this mantra but i have found
that accepting that it's part of my life
makes it welcome like if i wake up and i
don't feel anxiety these days i'm like
what's wrong like what am i not aware of
you know honestly it's it's taking a lot
of money a lot of professional help
a lot many many years but these days and
not that i don't
falter not that i don't sometimes just
get in my room and cry or something
but uh by and large i remind myself so i
watched genevieve go through
natural childbirth twice she said i do
it three times we had some issues with
our eight-year-old
his quarters around his neck twice it
was kinked and
we ended up going to hospital then but
then i watched her two times
give natural childbirth you know no
advil and she
had she didn't say those exact words but
i got that she was like
you know when they would when when there
would be contractions
she would sit there and breathe through
it she's a [ __ ] dog boss man
but she would breathe through it and
ultimately after the fact she was sort
of like you know i know it's gonna hurt
i know it's gonna go away
and there's a great it's not roomy it's
reiki maybe there's a great quote
about something um you know deal with
the highs deal with the lows i'm
bastardizing
but no feeling is final um
so accepting that accepting there will
be pain like that's part of
life life can suck for all of us and
like can be amazing for all of us if we
choose to focus on that
but dealing with like you know no
feeling is final
this is painful you don't have to suffer
inside of you is brought to you by
raycon
i think everybody's using these earbuds
every time i say it i'm like yeah
one of my sponsors is raycon they're
like yeah
they're awesome i mean a lot of my
friends have these earbuds
that i didn't know about until i got
them and most earbuds don't feel
comfortable for me
no and they're expensive is crap yeah
and so i'm like wow this is actually a
really good product
the sound is awesome and they're
actually comfortable for some reason my
ears are sensitive
and they're not sensitive with raycons
look guys whether you're working from
home or working on your fitness you you
want what you're listening to
to be what you are listening to not what
your roommates or your
friends or the other room or i don't
want to hear other things i get so
distracted with my add
you want to listen to what you are
listening to when you put on headphones
everyone needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds but before you drop
hundreds of dollars on a pair please
check out wireless earbuds from raycon
guys you already know raycon earbuds
started at about half the price
of any other premium wireless earbuds in
the market and they sound just as
amazing as other top audio brands you
know
their newest model the everyday e25
earbuds are their best ones yet
with six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth pairing more
bass space and the more compact design
that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit raycon's wireless
earbuds are so
freaking comfortable perfect for
conference calls or binging
podcasts and unlike some of the other
wireless options that are out there ryan
raycon earbuds are both stylish and
discreet with no dangling wires or stems
to distract anyone during video calls
the company was founded by ray j and
celebrities like
i gotta say brandy because you know i
love brandy yeah
and uh melissa etheridge i mean they're
obsessed with rakons including all my
friends who aren't celebrities
they're obsessed with them so now's the
time to get the latest and greatest from
raycon
get 15 off your order at buy raycon.com
iou that's by raycon.com
iou for 15 off raycon wireless earbuds
by raycon.com iou
this episode of inside of you is brought
to you by the jordan harbinger show
it's jordan harbinger i don't know if
you guys have heard this podcast but
it's it's pretty incredible i mean you
know as i talk to guests and get
information out of them
that people can kind of chew on and go
wow i got something out of that i think
this guy does the same thing in fact he
does the same thing and
he's just got a lot of great he's a good
interviewer and he's got
some great guests uh
danny trejo uh inmate number one
which is fantastic um
and one i really like is my future
versus my special needs sister
just the title right there says wow this
is interesting because you kind of get
it but you
you gotta listen to that uh i really
enjoy it
and i learned something from it and uh
it's the jordan
harbinger show search the jordan
harbinger show on apple podcast spotify
wherever you listen to podcast or go to
jordan jordanharbinger.com
subscribe this show covers a wide range
of topics through weekly interviews
heavy hitting guests
and there are a ton of episodes rooted
in the business and tech space
the jordan harbinger show is you know
the one constant is
is jordan's ability to pull useful
pieces of advice from his guests and and
that's sort of what i do in a different
way
guys we really enjoy the show and we
know you will too search the jordan
harbinger show that's h-a-r-b as in boy
i-n as in nancy g-e-r
on apple podcasts spotify or
ever you listen to podcasts the jordan
harbinger show are you excited
for this being i mean are you going to
miss the show like hell you're going to
miss
i could tell you're already missing i've
cried every day for a week you really
you genuinely cry
yeah i read the script every day um
and even just moments on set you know we
have we're
we're filming our last episode so every
now and again we're at a location it's
like oh i've been here 15 years i
remember this place i remember where
i played my dog and this and that and
it's like okay this is the last time
we'll be at this location
and i think to myself there's a
possibility i'm trying to be aware of
but i'll never make this drive again we
just shot um kind of
up c sky highway uh last week and on the
drive down it was our last day at that
location
and i was like oh my god like i might
never make this drive again i hope i do
i hope i do but i'm just preparing
myself to go like i might never see this
and i you know i would go to whistler on
weekends and go skiing or go hiking or
whatever the
season was um i'm really excited it's
very bittersweet
and apples and i talk every day about it
and
it's long days you know we have to
finish what we have to finish we don't
have any pickup shots
it's not like hey we'll come back in a
month because we've been quarantined for
two more weeks
and it doesn't make sense uh financially
did they schedule the last
very last final moment between you and
jensen
together so you're in the last shot
before you both rap at the same time
is that what's gonna happen i'll say
this
i'm trying to figure out the i'm saying
like ask two actors because they shoot
out of order are you guys going to be
together on the final take of the final
day
the last time sam and dean see each
other is the last time jared and jensen
see each other if that makes any sense
i'm not saying what the last scene is
going to be but the last
moment i have on camera with jensen and
vice versa will be the last
filming moment i have on camera with
jensen and how
emotional i could just see two of you
good-looking [ __ ] just
falling together oh my god sweating you
got the sauna
you guys got the sauna blanket over both
of you you're just crying your [ __ ]
eyes out
here it's already been emotional man you
know what's funny is that
um is that he and i both and you know
this you worked with him and you know me
for a long time and
he and i both are so committed to these
characters you know he plays dean
rochester i play san manchester
like i love sam winchester he's been my
close friend for 15 years
and i want to do him justice so i'm
focusing really hard i'm trying to focus
really hard
to make sure that if sam cries it's sam
tears not jared's
like at my heart like it wasn't
necessarily that i want to be famous
i want to be in a jbot magazine or
whatever i want to tell stories
and i want to tell sam's story and i i
did a christmas movie of season one
with uh you know jason ciccini yeah of
course yeah thomas
he's my dear dear friend and i hope he
comes down to austin
but um uh he did the move with me and
there was a scene i had with peter
o'toole who's one of my
idols and i i so badly wanted to impress
him and press the director
that i ended up getting to a place where
i kept crying after they called cut
and peter was like michael to the
director he's like can can jared and i
have a moment and mike was like
absolutely so he told everybody to take
10 minutes and go get the crafty or
something
and peter o'toole comes with me and says
hey
that was wonderful that was phenomenal
those are tom's tears i played a
character in thomas kincaid
tom and so he's like those are tom's
tears don't steal them
save them for tom and from a guy who
like went to radha you know eight-time
oscar nominee
lawrence of arabia my favorite year like
he i was like i'll be damned like what a
great
what a great thing and he was 80 at the
time i was 23 or 24.
um and he is he is peter o'toole and i
was like what a cool thing to say like
remember
i'm glad you got there that was
wonderful those aren't your tears
when they call action if tom cries give
them to him
wow just like a little thing that just
went so
oh you're like i've had that and it's
always from veteran actors
john glover um i don't yes i go i can't
i don't know what's going on john can't
do that
like um well just listen to me just
let's do let's just talk let's just
just it's just me and you it's you it's
your dad and i looked at him i go
oh my god roll cameras i got it
and then i go and i just listen now i'm
like what i forgot to listen
yeah all right hey listen i gotta ask
you because it's kind of funny now i
guess
yep when you got when you got arrested
yes you know because uh then you came on
set
and uh jensen had you in shackles
walking on set they were going to get
jumpsuits orange jumpsuits for the whole
crew
but they couldn't get them in time uh
you know
look i've always known you're like you
know you're one of those guys you always
have someone's back you always say
you're a boy you're uh
you know you have fun you get a huge
heart you're loving
but you know someone pisses you off or
you get a little you get a little rowdy
right
sure so what happened i don't even know
what happened uh i
this is not an excuse i don't entirely
know what happened either other than
reading the reports
and uh did you believe the reports i
have to yeah
yeah i have to uh long story short the
the um the cliff notes
are i we were filming in vancouver
and we flew i think we filmed like five
or six a.m
and flew to austin and we had a double
date that night jen and i had a double
date with our buddies walker and sandy
uh shout out walking sandy it went to
dinner and i hadn't slept i hadn't had
anything to eat
it's not like 8 p.m and we had a friend
who had opened up a bar
and it was it was the weekend before
halloween so it's like when everybody
gets dressed up
um and so we went to a buddies so we had
we had dinner and we you know we all
split a bottle of wine at a cocktail
this one time i haven't eaten i haven't
slept and i think i was a little bit
more affected than i
maybe wanted to admit and so we walked
down the block
um and went to a buddy who would open up
a new bar and i own a few bars in austin
and the community of barn is kind of
small you see each other and like hey
welcome like how you look at any place
and we had gone and um and
you know we get there and the the owner
is like hey
welcome how do you like it and there
were a couple bachelorette parties
and they were fans of the show like
let's buy you a drink and this net and i
think i had too much to drink
and uh too little to eat and sleep and i
i legitimately don't recall what
happened other than what i've seen
in the video but i think what happened
having seen in the video i think what
happened
is i just was blacked out
didn't know what's going on and i think
i saw me
get pulled down by my hair in the video
and then i thought i think i thought i
was in a fight
you know jensen i got jumped season one
outside of i remember
on richards and i think it was i think
my my my head
must have i haven't had a drink since i
was sort of like okay i'm gonna go ahead
and put this away because
i that is not who i am anybody who knows
me knows that's
the absolute opposite you know if
somebody's going to hurt my child
obviously i'm going to protect them i
don't know what happened that night well
it's not like you get in fights every
month this is like you know
two and 20 years this is not like i you
know it was very
humbling i guess never really talked
about it it's very humbling
to go that's like i judge these people
who i read about
like blah blah blah gets into a bar
fight i'm like what an idiot you're a
celebrity
like what's wrong with you don't take
drinks from people you don't know
and i was like whoa i just took drinks
from something and i don't know if i was
drugged or whatever but i i
completely i don't recall what happened
other than what i read in the police
reports
um yeah it's pretty humbling man it's
pretty uh
you haven't had a drink since no and the
people like
you always think about that if somebody
something happens i mean i'm sure people
probably come after you for money
right you would think so here's here's
the worst part of the story is i knew
the guys it was my bar
i knew them you know and so luckily they
were like
okay i don't know what the [ __ ] just
happened but that's not jared
we know him well enough to know that
like maybe he was drugged or something
and so
um so i talked with them and
and thank god they were like hey man
like that was really messed up but we
know that's not you
you know we've known you for plenty long
we've known friends of you we've known
people who just randomly ran into the
street you were really kind to
so we know that's nothing to do with who
you are as a human being
and you know we're good um so
i guess that's a blessing yeah so it
happened at boat
of course not i guess that's a blessing
that's a huge blessing that i i
i'm not that guy well you were amongst
people who know you
who knew you and know you're not that
guy and you for all these years you
haven't been
so it happened in front of people you
know as embarrassing as it might have
been
at least they could say that's not him i
know that yeah
he's just this is just not him i've seen
that before i've seen that with like a
somebody like you you think about things
that you're like
no no i don't believe that that's that's
not that guy it's just never happened
i've never seen it it was surreal
it was surreal i saw i ended up seeing
security footage because i had to watch
it was it hard to watch
yeah yeah really hard to watch because
you're watching it and you're like
that's me and you don't know you don't
see what you're doing and that's why i
was like i i can i'm never going there
again i'm never risking going there
again i don't do drugs
you know i i obviously enjoyed wine and
stuff like that but i was like i've
never
been to a point where you're literally
seeing yourself
on a screen you know obviously if you're
acting you see an episode of gilmore
girls supernatural you're like
oh yeah i remember memorizing those
lines remember blocking but you see
yourself
at 1am or whatever outside of a bar on a
security footage
you're like no that that doesn't it's
it's almost like twilight zone well that
had to be you had to be drugged
i'm not an excuse kind of guy like i
hate excuses my dad was very much like
you know oh dead i have time what did
you do between 1 am and 5 am
i slept so you did have time like i'm a
no excuses kind of guy i don't like that
excuse
but that's never happened to me you know
i didn't drink i've had more to drink
and not blacked out
um and i don't know what happened i
i broke my own rule of like and i tell
genevieve and we have a daughter and i'm
like you know never take a drink
somebody pours for you
and that night for whatever reason i was
like oh thanks it's a bachelorette party
it's my friend's bar
like nothing could have happened and by
the way this is how much this is what
i'm thinking i'm not just saying this is
a friend
but especially if you're at a a place
where it's yours and it's all
people you know and you're that's yeah
it's not like you're at some random
place where there's nobody you know
it's it's if you were more aware of what
was going on
you wouldn't have done that if you had
any kind of you know it just
that's what i whatever yeah whatever
happened i i still uh
it's a it's it's it's it's definitely
informed my life since then you know
that was ten months ago
and um you know i just was like i'm
gonna stop drinking so i stopped and
i've been talking to my psychiatrist a
lot about it and where i might have
stemmed from and what
happened outside of whatever may have
been poured anything i had to drink or
eat
um well i'm glad i'm black
panic mode i thought i was getting
attacked you know i thought i was
getting
shoved and pushed i think i this is wild
ass guess like again
i'm not proud of it but i don't remember
i don't remember it um
i'm certainly not proud of them
humiliated by it uh but
yeah i assume i just thought i was gonna
get
beat up you know i've been jumped before
many times
by a bunch of guys and you're like well
if they beat me up they're gonna get me
on the ground
and kick my head into a curb like
american history x or something like
i can't i need to protect myself and i
assume that's where
i was where i was thinking you know what
i was thinking
right but yeah it was a it was a
luckily you know that's in the past
where it will stay
you know and absolutely let's talk about
something really good
and then by the way you know it's it's
humid it's like you know
celebrities friends athletes they come
on this podcast
people don't want to hear about
everybody's life is perfect and no one
makes mistakes no i don't get anxiety
and i don't get
so for you to get up here and be honest
about what you just [ __ ] talked about
if anybody has an
issue with that it's like don't listen
to the show because you're vulnerable
and you're real and you're like hey this
is what happened you don't make excuses
you're like you don't
bear you're embarrassed by it you make
changes things happen and
you know uh so that's what i'll say
about that but um
texas ranger texas walker
yeah walker i always say texas ranger i
know you do
texas walker are you excited about the
show i'm thrilled
i'm thrilled when do you start well
uh before the pandemic we were gonna
finish
uh supernatural on april 5th and then
start walker
april 20th and then obviously you know
global pandemic that's
like unlike anything we've ever seen and
for several generations
um and so right now i think we're set
we're set to finish supernatural on
september 10th
and then we were supposed to start
walking on september 23rd
but that got pushed uh because we need
more time to build i think so it's going
to be hopefully sometime in october
we start in austin how many episodes i
don't know again
i don't know um i think it was supposed
i think we got a 13 episode pickup
don't quote me on this i probably should
know this um i think we got a 13
pickup but then i think because of
everything going on
it'll just depend as you well know and
maybe some of your
uh listening viewing audience doesn't
know tv shows episode tv shows usually
shoot from july to april
so if we can't start till uh october
as of now late october then if we did
the same amount of episodes we would
shoot like into july or august
which means if we got picked up for a
season two then
there would be overlap so i don't know
if i don't know i think that's going to
be
at the at the mercy of a lot of
different networks like abc
fox cbs nbc cw like i feel like they're
all gonna have to go like hey guys
let's all agree on like a 10 episode
season for 2020 like a coveted season
let's do a short season and get back to
normal moving forward but again
god knows man you love to work you're
just like jensen you guys just have to
work you want to work you love acting
you love it and i love that it's great
yeah
all right this is real quick this is
called [ __ ] talking with rosamounts
quick this is rapid fire
toms asks will there be a supernatural
movie coming out in the future and would
you do one
i hope so and absolutely steph
a are you hoping to channel your inner
chuck norris for walker or are you going
to make the
roll your own interpretation uh
my my walker
has zero to do with with chuck's walker
i did watch chuck norris i mean i grew
up in texas
and walker text ranger was obviously a
massive show and i watched it
but this is a brand new character brand
new story and brand new era
so brand asked me is he related to that
guy at all no no
no his name's walker he's a texas ranger
but he has nothing to do with walker
texas ranger
from yesteryear cordell's the new walker
texas journal
uh leanne have you had any uh paranormal
experiences of your own that you would
like to share
that's a random one i certainly i have
seen some things
and experienced some things that i can't
explain but as far as specifically one
like there was a time where this
happened
uh definitively no but possibly yes
all right rachen have you talked with
chuck norris about his
about about this at all is he supportive
of you taking over his iconic role even
though
i know it's a different role have you
have you had his blessing or have you
talked to him
well he uh great question so i have not
talked to him directly
we've had i guess our people have talked
whatever that means
um but he had to give his blessing
because he still co-owned
the rights to the uh the story the
product
you know so he owned he was part of the
uh
ep group and he had some ownership in
walker texas ranger
so we had to get his blessing to to
create a new version of it so i know we
have his blessing
but i don't know what his involvement
will or won't be you know he's yeah
i think he's 80 something now i'm sure
you can still be my ass let me give you
an example this is this is the phone
conversation
yeah uh chuck yeah
hey it's ron over here at uh warner
brothers
uh yeah listen uh so they're redoing the
show
sort of it's kind of a new thing uh yeah
come on hurry up i gotta tell you
yeah listen we're doing uh the show
walker texas ranger i get paid people
yeah you own part of it all right [ __ ]
it do it
does he have to pee a lot or was that
just uh he just wanted to get off the
phone
chuck wanted to get off the phone and
get his num chucks and take a [ __ ] i
think
personally that he probably if somebody
goes
you're the part owner of that they want
to redo it
do i get paid well look yeah why are you
asking me of course
don't do it whatever yeah
but fair enough uh last question daniel
m if you had a chance which superhero
could you see yourself playing
because you're a big guy you're a
handsome fellow what would it be thanks
man
i'm a big guy uh i've heard nighthawk
would be a good fit for me which would
be fun
um
yeah i think i've seen some mock-ups of
nighthawk did you test screen
didn't you test screen for uh lex luthor
or for success clark yeah not the small
bill i test
i i screen tested for the movie in o4
when it was mcgee yeah i was doing a
house of wax and i flew
from they flew me from australia to l.a
to screen test i put the suit on and
everything they took my phone away so i
could take pictures
uh do you know by the way that jensen
gets the car we both get a car
you get the car too we both get a car
yeah it was in your contract as well
it wasn't in either of our contracts it
was a gift from them but that funny
thing is also
i'm the i'm actually the car guy like i
i
my first car ever was a 69 camaro i
still have it i also had a c6 mustang he
had like broncos and stuff
um but i'm the car guy like when i see a
67 impala
i'm like okay what's a block like was it
a was it a board stroke got some rotary
girders on here you got
everybody needs rotary girders uh yeah
but i grew up like cliffy and i
who works in the show he and i have
taught cars for years my favorite car
ever is a 67 corvette
my dad's favorite car but i have like
car books and
parts books from when i was [ __ ]
seven years old you could build an
engine you could rebuild an engine
i cannot i can i can tinker with a
carburetor engine you know i know spark
plugs
i could change my oil i could change a
tire i could change my oil i can change
oil i can change oil on a classic car i
mean these days
yeah a lift system you need a fine tooth
comb to get in there
but you give me an old late 60s uh
muscle car and i can
i can fiddle you know i can change i
used to keep a fan belt
and uh some spark plugs in my 69 camaro
that i drove to high school
i still have the car like i i am the
classic car guy
like that's so you're both getting a car
so the question is
oh no that wasn't contractual that was
phenomenal that warner brothers did for
us right okay it's a phenomenal like hey
they probably could have sold the cars
for a million dollars a piece i mean i'm
throwing out a number
but those cars are very valuable and
peter
uh said basically thank you guys so much
for doing
such a wonderful job for so long we'd
like
you guys to have this and dean
winchester's the car guy but jared
padillac he's the car guy
by the way that show made so much money
for that network i hope so it's a great
show
yeah it's a great show you deserve it
absolutely look dude this is awesome i i
honestly i i want to
i wish i could talk to you every week
but you know it's like how many yeah
yeah but this is awesome
i wish you the best it's it's so
exciting i mean this is how many years
15. however 15 but 15 is part one and
two so
uh i turned 37 and 38 on season 15.
because it got split up wow so season 15
it's like a show that
you can't get rid of us well you told me
you and jensen both were like well come
up and play with us man come up we'll
get
we'll get you on and i never did and i'm
like you know if you guys do a freaking
movie of it
you got to find something well listen
man gilmore girls uh
did i did five seasons they did seven
and then
10 years later they did a netflix reboot
so movie or reboot
give me a call i'm i uh oh man man
it's gonna happen i love the show i love
the fandom the family
so dude i love you man this has been
fantastic all right yeah come here
good to see your face me too buddy
i love jared don't you good dude he is a
good dude he's good too that fight story
i could just tell he was uncomfortable
in in a sort of like i know i felt like
he did want to kind of talk about it got
it off his chest a little bit
yeah i mean he was definitely
embarrassed by it but it's sort of good
to
you know get it out there i think so uh
i just love his
his honesty and i love that they're both
getting cars
that's fun right uh shout out to all my
patreons out there thank you again if
you like the show
again please subscribe please tell your
friends
spread it to the world and again if
you're still listening and you
at this point i think if you're
listening and you know
and you're a supernatural fan you came
here because you're a jared fan or a
jensen fan
stick around man listen to other
episodes i think you'll like it
i hope you'll like it and uh big shout
out to all the patrons
big [ __ ] out big [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] out
let's push it out
time for the [ __ ] out with the patrons
thanks to all you folks uh you i mean
you know what you do
you uh you're wonderful nancy d mary b
leah s trish sarah v lillisa
yukiko jill e lauren g nico p
angelina g lee robin asks jerry w
emily k bob b robert i jason w stephen j
kristen k amelia o allison l
tom and jess n no just jay
lucas m raj emily
emily s we know who you are cjp samantha
m humza
jennifer n jackie p stacy l carly
h jennifer s janelle b
tabitha 272 not to be confused with
273 kimberly e crystal h mike e marissa
n ramirez beth b chris f
sarah f chad w leanne p rachel c
ray a maya p megan j jennifer c matty s
tiffany i kendrick f ashley e margie m
thomas t matt w belinda and benjamin r
lisa j kevin v robert s
joy w james r chris h
snow r noah k
sean v and oshborn h i think it's
ashborne
uh guys thank you again for listening i
i hope you had a great time uh
keep it up and if you like this one
there's a lot of others to go back and
listen to and get caught up make sure
you subscribe and all that stuff and uh
the store inside of you store uh we got
new shirts we've got tons of great stuff
i even have a couple horror hats left
couple sweatshirts left mugs autographed
mugs
all that jazz and uh band shirts
rosenbaumandanson.com
rosenbaum and danson d-a-n-s-o-n.com you
can get band shirts
really cool so uh that's it
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you have an
amazing week
be safe um do something kind
for someone this week if you can
whatever it is an act of kindness
open up the door for someone you know
tell someone they look nice unless
you're the boss at work
that could get you in trouble don't tax
taxiderma your dog
and tell your family you love them i
guess that's it all right all my love
see ya